Mit einem traktor strahlen können in star trek oder star wars fremde raumschiffe festgehalten
manövrierunfähige schiffe abgeschleppt oder unerwünschte objekte
Abgestoßen werden und wer jetzt denkt das ist doch alles science fiction krempe nichts
Da einem forschungsteam aus bristol ist es jetzt tatsächlich gelungen mit schallwellen
kugeln durch die luft fliegen zu lassen und der hammer jeder kann sich das gerät nachbauen wie das genau
funktioniert und ob das schon in zukunft auch mit echten raumschiffen klappt jetzt endlich zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja schon seit jahrzehnten versuchen
Forschungsteams weltweit das konzept, des traktor strahls aus star trek und star wars auch in der realität umzusetzen
2015 war es erstmals gelungen eine traktor strahl aus schall zu erzeugung jetzt hat ein forschungsteam aus brüssel
einen traktor strahl auf basis von schallwellen ganz einfach selbst konstruiert dadurch können objekte wie durch geisterhand
nicht nur einfach angehoben sondern auch angezogen werden wie der traktor strahl aus science fiction filmen die
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler nutzen dafür
schrauben förmige wirbel aus ultraschall diese wurden dem experiment von spezial lautsprechern abgefeuert
So wurden den mini styropor körnchen ständig winzige stöße von allen seiten verpasst die
Virtuellen wirbel so das forschungsteam macht es also möglich die kugeln stabil in der schwebe zu halten und noch mehr
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
Asia x er kann die objekte an die quelle der schallwellen heranziehen es ist sehr leicht
Partikel von der schallquelle wegzuschieben oder sie einfach nur in der schwebe zu halten aber sie
Anzuziehen ist etwas ganz anderes und das wirklich tolle ihr könnt euch selbst einen solchen
traktor strahl basteln forschungsteam
Aus brüssel hat das gerät so vereinfacht das ist jetzt mit einfachen bauteilen aus dem 3d drucker
Und dem internet gebaut werden kann
Am ende sieht das gerät dann aus wie eine überdimensionierte
taschenlampe in einem video beschreiben die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler wie man das gerät
zusammenbauen kann, am ende lassen sich damit weniger
der kleine objekte anheben und anziehen bei größeren objekten
Sei dass mit diesem konzept bislang nicht möglich gewesen kugel mit einem größeren durchmesser
Bekamen durch die schall wirbel einen drall und wurden. Aus dem fokus. Des traktor strahls gefeuert offenbar
Beschränkte die schallwellen länge die größe des traktor strahlt, so das fazit. Des forschungsteams in einem weiteren experiment
veränderten sie alle paar millisekunden die drehrichtung der schall band so wurden sogar bis zu
1,6 zentimeter große styropor körnchen stabil in der schwebe gehalten und das ist echt ziemlich riesig
nach berechnungen der wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler sollten sich objekte mit einer dichte bis zu 1,25 gramm pro kubikzentimeter
annehmen lassen heißt also
im klartext auch eine taufliege ließe sich per traktor strahl einfangen
Diese konzepte könnten demnächst auch in der medizin anwendung finden beispielsweise und medikamente innerhalb des menschlichen körpers zu
transportieren in ferner zukunft könnte man dann gegebenfalls auch ganze menschen schweben lassen
Bisher dachte man dass dies nur mit sehr extremen schallwellen möglich sei doch
Da wäre die verletzungsgefahr für uns menschen eventuell viel zu hoch und jetzt zurück zum weltraum in diesem bereich würde das konzept, des traktors
Realistisch gesehen große probleme mit sich bringen denn schall kann sich im vakuum also
Im weltraum nicht ausbreiten also müssen andere
wellen quellen verwendet werden und auch hier dürfte den forschungsteams dran doch mit laserstrahlen
lassen sich bisher damit nur objekte bewegen die deutlich weniger als einen millimeter
messen wenn er als erstes neues zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen themen und erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an
Dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von klicks um mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür. Draufklicken star wars todesstern laser gebaut ansonsten dann
bleibt dran